wow
[Applause]
[Music]
what's up everyone and welcome to the
first edition of a geek pong and this is
right brought to you by geek culture in
anticipation of the 26th film in the
marvel cinematic universe
eternals opening up island wide in
singapore on november 4th now as we know
eternals are relatively new characters
to the mcu but a lot of people don't
know the names and the powers and the
capabilities of these characters so
that's what we're going to learn here
today through the legendary game known
as
fear paw
but without beer what in the cups
is knowledge instead of beer
[Applause]
[Laughter]
these questions range from easy to hard
all right and the hard ones are very
challenging that's right now we got two
teams of courses because here today team
snap abby jen and gerald from geek
culture
[Applause]
and team emergence
we'll put it here at the bottom of the
screen as well
are you guys ready for deep pawn yeah
let's begin
so
who shall go first team snapper team
emergence
i'll decide team emergence will go first
muna you're the first stop
actually sandia
what by the way guys just heads up if
one team misses putting the ball in the
cup it will go up to the next team back
and forth until ball goes into the cup
all right you must bounce the ball to
get into the cup luna no pressure okay
so much pressure
everything is on you got this don't
listen to them
she can't help with responsibility
what are cersei's powers
ah
this is
[Applause]
[Music]
think of a very high-end restaurant that
does this to their food other than
everything else that cesi can do
is also able to
is focusing on
mommy that's not bad it's not bad hey
this is my game
we're not in science class this is
eternals okay so next goes to team snap
abby you're up first
[Applause]
okay here we go
what are ajax powers
one points to heal healing is
[Applause]
all right come on gerald i know you've
done a few games
in your time i have i have it's pretty
easy
let's go
[Applause]
[Music]
nice it's a green how many members
comprise the full team of eternals oh
come on
it is
five five five plus five make it ten
ten is correct
one point that's not fun currently we're
at two to one right
two to one team emergence okay
you're dressed up for this yeses and
everything
[Applause]
okay
have you watched any of the trailers
you may know the answer to this then
in the trailer you see a couple being
paired up name the actors playing the
characters
so five points
[Applause]
you all got to get your balls in the
cups here really quick
[Applause]
an easy question the eternals are guided
to protect humanity by which group of
ancient beings beings celestials yes so
much yours is correct
you are asking the questions that
[Applause]
team emergency is in the lead
give me answers
so now i go to my
what other venues
i have a special series of questions
that are extremely hard
here we go the synopsis describes the
eternals as ancient aliens who have been
living on earth in secret for thousands
of years
does anyone know the rough number of
years they have been on earth
seven thousand
is correct
[Applause]
do you guess or do you know i i read
some stuff
prior every time
[Applause]
which character does angelina jolie play
oh hey
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
what are gilgamesh's powers he's like
really strong
[Music]
no yes yes yes super strength superior
hand to hand in combat yeah okay
[Applause]
what are icarus's powers
here is so cool you know
here he can shoot things from the eyes
this kind of thing
and pro and spider webs fly
you're right and you're actually right
he fly an energy blast from the eyes
so there you go yeah very cool
[Applause]
give me advantage witchcraft
[Music]
okay
if the eternals have been on earth for 7
000 years
and one of them is deaf
does it mean
they were the ones that created sign
language first
[Music]
there's always a possibility when did
the dinosaurs
[Laughter]
this
is actually there's no right or wrong
answer to this but it's a question that
maybe will be answered in the film
opening up island wide on november 4th
so i have another question
[Applause]
luna here is your question
with this you could win the entire game
what is the name
of the event
that brings the eternals together again
that's an odd question yeah are you sure
that's a hard question
you're the one that wrote it
you betrayed us
wow what have you done
what have you done i'd like to bring
this home please yes
this was actually the only thing i read
from the brain
are you charging up your superpowers
my answer is
emergence
and that is the correct answer
team emergence
he's victorious
with ten points
[Applause]
team staff
you're fired
you have a lot of knowledge yeah but you
really just don't know how to balance
balls
you gotta learn how to bounce balls you
gotta practice this for the next edition
okay definitely all right all right
what is the prize
well for you guys there's nothing you
guys go home
but for team emergence
you now
have on your mantel
that award
to be the first ever winners of butte
palm
i'm going to change my instagram bio yes
right now yeah it just needs to be done
yes
is there a forfeit what is there forfeit
for the losers do they have to do
anything
they just have to go back in shame
because they write these articles
anyway guys catch eternals coming out
island-wide november 4th of that take
care stay safe and we'll see you very
soon
bye
you're about to meet the greatest
warriors the world has ever known this
november legendary fashionable
powerful
well i'm sure that was a lot of fun for
you it was
marvel studios eternals only in cinemas